bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien je voulais faire une vidéo pour les
débutants dans le zéro déchet parce que
on se retrouve avec plein d'habitude a
changé depuis quelques années fanni a
pris conscience de la nécessité de
réduire ses déchets petit à petit à la
modifier ses habitudes et même commencé
à dispenser ses conseils sur internet
aboutissement logique de sa démarche
elle a ouvert il ya un an en plein coeur
de tours une épicerie sous franchise et
surtout sans emballage et fanny
apparemment est loin d'être seul dans ce
combat pour réduire le poids de nos
poubelles
c'est génial de voir les clients qui
font leurs courses comme ça qu'ils
prennent conscience au fur et à mesure
de l'importance de réduire ses déchets
j'ai beaucoup de clientèle de quartier
et moi et au début les gens voient la
découvre et prenez des petites quantités
dans des petits sachets en papier parce
que vous avez des petits sachets en
papier et au fur et à mesure ils
viennent avec leurs bocaux petit à petit
ses équipes
et puis font leurs courses ils ont même
plus besoin des petits sachets
maintenant pourquoi ce choix de faire
vos courses en vrac pour diminuer les
déchets principalement et donc pour
diminuer l'empreinte écologique de mon
foyer faut que les gens ils commencent à
prendre conscience de tout ce qui jette
à la poubelle tous les emballages tous
les voilà la facilité de de tout ce
qu'on peut acheter dans les supermarchés
dans les
dans les drives auparavant libraires en
région parisienne anne gwénolé vient
elle aussi d'ouvrir une épicerie sans
emballage dans le même quartier
près de 400 références en vrac donc et
pour l'essentiel des produits bio et
locaux
pour moi c'est juste du bon sens le bio
c'est un investissement pour la planète
et aussi pour notre bien-être personnel
le local c'est parce qu'à mon sens je
préfère collaborer et travailler avec
des gens de ma région
des maraîchers qui sont
qui sont là qui font des bons produits
plutôt que de faire importer des tomates
et des courgettes d'espagne
c'est à la mode en ce moment mais moi
j'ai toujours attaché de l'importance à
acheter le plus directement possible aux
producteurs j'achète aussi à des des
paysans qui transforme même leur
production j'aime bien le côté donc
locale le côté vente directe et le côté
0 emballages c'est aussi c'est aussi top
parce que je suis de plus en plus
obnubilé par les suremballages c'est
pareil on en parle de plus en plus donc
c'est c'est bien c'est bien que ça
émergent ce sujet autre credo dan
gwénolé faire ses courses ne doit plus
être une corvée
et il est vrai que dans ces épiceries ou
commerçants et clients partagent
certaines convictions les relations
semblent beaucoup moins impersonnel que
dans les commerces traditionnels